-Our next guest represents
Maryland's
8th Congressional District
and was the lead
impeachment manager.
Please welcome to the show
Congressman Jamie Raskin.
Thanks for being here,
Congressman.
-I'm delighted to be with you,
Seth. Thanks for having me
-So, many were introduced to you
as the lead impeachment manager.
Many, from both sides
of the aisle,
said you did a great job
and that the defense
maybe didn't.
Were you surprised
by the preparation level
of Donald Trump's legal team
during the impeachment?
-Mm.
Well, let's see.
We don't speak ill
of fellow members of the bar
but, when Mr. Castor finishe
that very long-winded opening,
something ran through my mind,
that I'd heard in a scienc
class when I was in college.
A professor
who quoted a physicist
who read someone else's pape
and said,
"That's not even wrong."
-[ Laughs ]
-Like I kind of felt like
he had never even addresse
the issues in the case
or the facts of the case
and so it wasn't like
he got up and struck out.
He just never
really found the stadium.
-Now, the one argument that ca
be made for that approach is
he was probably fairly confident
that his client was not goin
to get impeached.
You went into it maybe a littl
more confident than that.
I have heard you say you thought
you were going to win
with a unanimous Senate vote
100-0, voting to impeach.
Voting to convict, I should say.
-Well, yeah, I thought tha
the evidence in the case
was so overwhelming that
a Senate that was doing its jo
of rendering
"impartial justice,"
which is the oath
that they swore to uphold,
could do nothing other
than vote to convict.
And, as you say, he was alread
impeached by the House,
so we had the strongest
bipartisan majority in the House
in American history
for impeachment.
And then, it came to the Senat
and I thought that we
would get to 100-0,
that the bottom would just fal
out on the president's defense
but there were obviously peopl
who had decided,
at the beginning, that they were
going to vote to acquit hi
and hang their hat
on this technical defense,
that he couldn't be tried
after leaving office,
even though he was impeached
for actions that he undertoo
while he was in office,
which has been the traditional
American approach,
going back to the very beginning
of the Constitution.
-Do you think that the results
would've been different
in the vote to convict,
had it been a blind vote,
where people
would not have known
how each senator
made their choice?
-Yes, and a lot of Republicans
were saying that to me,
that, if they had made
the decision
to structure the rules
of the Senate differently,
if it had been a secret ballot
which is basically what you've
got when a real jury meets
When a jury meets,
the public doesn't know
who's voting in which directio
and so, if they had decide
to do the same thing,
I think that would've
made a difference.
I also kick myself, Seth,
because I wish that I had moved,
at the beginning,
to do something they hadn'
even considered,
which was to keep them
from sitting in partisan blocks.
You know, they had
the Republicans
over on the right side
and the Democrats
over on the left side.
They should've been seated
alphabetically or something else
because it encouraged them
to keep thinking of it
in partisan terms,
when the whole trick is
to get them to render
an impartial verdict.
And that word, "impartial"
is a lot like "nonpartisan."
-Obviously, you know,
we're watching via the cameras
and you made
a very riveting case.
Did you feel as though you had
the attention of the senator
when you were making it?
-We had the attention
of every senator
who was paying attention,
and the reason I say that is
because I looked out often
and saw not a majority,
at all, of the Republicans
but a handful of Republicans
who were studiously refusing
to look at the camera
when we showed footage
of the violent insurrection,
the attacks
on the police officers,
the people chanting, you know,
"Hang Mike Pence!
Hang Mike Pence!
Traitor! Traitor! Traitor!
They were essentially
closing their eyes to it
and, for that, I won't forgive
any of the senators.
I mean, it's one thing
to get to the end and say,
"I wasn't persuaded
by your case,"
or "I think jurisdictionally
even though this is
a radically novel argument
the president can't be tried
once he's left office,"
but it's quite another to say,
"I'm not even going to loo
at the facts of the case."
So, those people,
those people, I'm not goin
to give for a long time.
-Obviously, they probably
don't teach, in law school
how to make a case to a jury
who are also witnesses
to the crime
and, one could even argue,
coconspirators.
How do you approach laying out
a case to a roomful of peopl
who were there
and saw it with their own eyes
-Well, you would've thought that
that would make
our job a lot easier,
because it's like getting
a jury full of people
who were there
when the crime was committed
and the crime was committe
in the courtroom
because we were meeting in one
of the places, you remember,
that the insurrectionists
stormed and took over.
They had their feet up
on all these people's desks.
They were rifling
their belongings
and, if you've got any kin
of professional
or democratic self-respect
at all,
you would think you'd go i
saying, you know,
"The president's going
to pay for this,
if he's the one
who got this thing started,"
which, of course, he did.
So I was startled
that 43 of them
were willing to just look
the other way and say,
"No, this guy's got
too much power in our party,
and, even though,
if you're with Mitch McConnell
we made an overwhelming case
we proved our case on the facts,
still, they were going to clai
that the president
could not be tried,
once he's left office,
thereby creating what we wer
calling the January exception --
you can get away
with whatever you want,
once you hit January --
a coup, a rebellion,
an insurrection,
lining up members of Congress,
taking people hostage.
I mean, it's an absurdity,
when you think about it.
And I quoted, you know,
Voltaire, who said,
"Anybody who can make you
believe absurdities
can make you commit atrocities."
And I think
that captures pretty well
the whole course of our histor
over the last few years.
I mean, Donald Trump really wa
convincing people, somehow
he had won the election,
when he lost by more
than seven million votes.
It was a landslide,
on his own terms,
in the Electoral College
and, yet, there are still people
walking around like zombie
in Congress today,
saying that Donald Trump
won the election.
-Obviously, to pick up something
like being
the impeachment manager,
that requires a great deal
of patriotism
to take a job like this.
This was a time -- and we want
to pass along our condolences --
you tragically
lost your son last year
and to take up
this very difficult job
that obviously required a lo
of your time, focus,
and energy --
was it important for you
to channel that grief
into something that mattered
as much as this?
-I think so.
My son Tommy,
who was in his second year
at Harvard Law School,
was a great champion of the rule
of law and the rule of law
as an instrument of justic
and democracy
and I felt him very much
next to my heart
and in my chest
over the course of the trial
And, for me, it was important --
I just kept thinking,
"I'm not going to lose my so
on the last day of 2020
and lose my country in 2021.
We have got to establish
that this is
completely off-limits
conduct and behavior.
We can never allow anything like
that to happen to us again -
to have a president
who basically incites
a violent attack
to overturn an election,
in order to install himsel
in office.
And so I felt Tommy with me,
as well as my my daughters
Hannah and Tabitha;
and Sarah, my wife;
my whole family;
and all of my colleagues.
And, as you know, Seth,
we had just a remarkable tea
of impeachment managers
and they will be my brothers
and sisters forever,
after what we
went through there.
-Well, we thank you
for what you put
into the historical record
and thank you so much
for making time for us today
Really appreciate it.
-I appreciate your having me
Seth. Best to you.